en el vídeo pasado estábamos en este
ejemplo que es el ejemplo que sigo y
sigo usando en el cual yo me invento un
banco en este ejemplo en vez de dar el
oro así de las bóvedas directamente para
hacer préstamos y que se usará para
proyectos y luego volviera a entrar y lo
préstamos otra vez lo que hicimos es que
el banco cada vez que hacía un préstamo
simplemente lo hacía creaba un activo y
creaba un pasivo correspondiente donde
el pasivo era una cuenta de cheques o
bien eran notas bancarias que
esencialmente era efectivo con lo cual
pues el emprendedor ya podía pagarle a
sus empleados o comprar bienes ahora una
pregunta obvia era que tanto el banco
puede seguir haciendo esto o sea cuando
tiene que detenerse un poco puedes
seguir haciendo crecer su hoja de
balance para responder esto te voy a
platicar un poquito acerca de la noción
de coeficiente de reserva antes nada más
como repaso y para asegurarme que
estamos leyendo bien la hoja de balance
déjame etiquetarlo no vaya a ser que a
ver esto de aquí son todo esto de acá
todo lo de la izquierda son activos lo
voy a marcar así con una línea bien bien
remarcada todo esto de aquí son los
del banco de sal incluyendo el edificio
verdad incluyendo la bóveda y luego el
pasivo lo voy a hacer en otro color en
color rojo el pasivo queda a la derecha
todo esto de aquí es pasivo pero ojo
nada más hasta aquí aquí y aquí llegan
los pasivos con este color rojo que
estoy utilizando y el capital de
capitales o sea lo que es propiedad de
los dueños ya sea muchas personas o solo
yo pues es lo de acá abajo este de acá
es el capital capital va entonces la
pregunta es perdón a ver estoy acá no le
puse dije que es todo esto de aquí es
pasivo pasivo
ok ahora sí entonces la pregunta es
cuánto puede un banco seguir y seguir
prestando a abriendo cuentas de cheques
sacando notas bancarias y así entonces
por ejemplo aquí aquí que pasó pues hizo
un préstamo de 100 piezas de oro verdad
y en vez de darle a de este 100 piezas
de oro de la bóveda simplemente creó una
cuenta de cheques para de que luego pasó
a a porque le construyó una fábrica y
por eso ahorita dice ah y ahora déjame
marcar acá también con amarillo para ver
cuál es la parte así en oro en metal
duro todo esto de acá es el que es el
oro
lo voy a pintar así con un amarillo este
aquí es el metal que si se tiene en las
bóvedas va esto de aquí en total son 500
piezas de oro muy bien entonces vamos a
introducir el concepto de coeficiente de
reserva
voy a escribirlo aquí coeficiente de
reserva coeficiente de bueno primero
vamos a pensar que es que es reserva una
reserva es algo que apartas así por
cualquier cosa por si llegan y piden
dinero en fin en esta situación todos
los pasivos ya sea que son notas
bancadas que sean notas bancarias o que
sean cuentas de cheques que significan
pues todas estas de aquí son promesas
del banco vaya son deudas de modo que
cualquier persona puede llegar y pedir
oro por ellas
entonces si por alguna razón yo me
quiero ir de la ciudad
voy a no confío en sal ya me quiero ir a
las bahamas lo que sea no tengo ni que
dar razón entonces puedo llegar a
ventanilla pedir mi dinero y el banco
tiene que darme lo estas son cuentas
exigibles al momento tanto las notas
bancarias como las cuentas de cheques
son
instrumentos que se pueden cambiar por
oro así al momento bueno este baja
entonces para esto tuvimos que haber
dejado un poquito de oro en caso de que
alguien de que alguien que sea tu
cliente quiera cobrar su oro entonces
esta cantidad de dinero que tienes que
apartar como una reserva comparado con
la cantidad total de pasivo o más bien
de pasivo exigible al momento esa razón
es el coeficiente de reserva entonces
estoy aquí y bueno claro en este mundo
que inventamos las reservas verdad y en
este en este mundo el material para
hacer una reserva es oro después cuando
nos salgamos del patrón oro la reserva
ya no va a ser oro van a hacer otras
cosas puede ser no sé bienes nacionales
o efectivo o lo que sea por el momento
vamos a quedarnos con el oro porque así
hemos estado trabajando entonces el
coeficiente de reserva es la cantidad de
activo en oro esto otra vez esto de aquí
ya casi no lo vas a ver porque ya casi
todos se salieron del patrón oro
entonces esto ya desde aquí ya casi no
se ve pero bueno en este mundo es la
cantidad de oro
dividido entre el pasivo total pero no
quiere decir el pasivo total porque el
banco podría tener préstamos de otro
tipo que no sean cuentas exigibles así
al instante entonces pues ahorita
tenemos puras de estas verduras que si
son exigibles pero pues vamos a hacer un
poco más precisos verdad por ejemplo
puede haber otro préstamo pues un poco
más regular que se tenga que pagar en no
sé pues diez años o algo así entonces
pues no tenemos por qué tener oro
apartado porque no van a venir a
pedirnos lo luego luego entonces vamos a
poner la definición así como el pasivo
total exigible bueno todo el pasivo es
exigible pero pensemos en inmediatamente
exigible total
exige un brinco exigible va entonces
cuánto sería la cantidad total de pasivo
exigible pues sería el total de notas
bancarias que se han emitido that las
notas bancarias pues pues las notas
bancarias después vamos vamos a meternos
a un mundo en donde sólo hay un banco
que emite notas bancarias hasta vista
nuestro ejemplo va siguiendo el contexto
histórico pero bueno tenemos el total de
notas bancarias y el total que está en
las cuentas de cheques pues esto de aquí
también es exigible verdad son cuentas
exigibles las de las cuentas de cheques
vamos a ver cuánto es la cantidad de oro
total es 500 piezas de oro y la cantidad
total de activos de pasivos exigibles se
sabe de 100 más 100 más 100 300 y 100
400 600 y este de acá arriba creo que
eran otros 100 700 entonces el
coeficiente de reserva es igual a ver
abajo es 700 es el pasivo total exigible
y el activo en oro
500 piezas de oro es 500 muy bien 500
bar entonces ahorita hay un coeficiente
de reserva en este banco bien alto es
cinco séptimos vamos a ver cuánto es
cinco séptimos a ver 5 cuántas veces
caben siete creo que 62 a ver si estoy
haciendo las cuentas mentalmente bien si
verdad 7 cabe en 17 cabe siete veces en
50 verdad entonces más bien sería 7
sobre una otra vez 71 por ciento son 71
por ciento entonces eso de ahí sería el
coeficiente de reserva ahora lo que
detiene que los bancos sigan emitiendo y
emitiendo préstamos y emitiendo fácil
bueno creando pasivos es un requisito de
coeficiente de reserva ahorita cuando
estamos en este mundo donde el banco
tiene todas todos sus respaldos en oro
verdad y entonces vamos a suponer que en
este mundo el gobierno dice sabes que
debes de tener un coeficiente de reserva
te voy a pedir un coeficiente de un
requisito de coeficiente de reserva
entonces son requisitos de reserva y voy
a pedir que no sé que sea 20 por ciento
para que estemos más o menos así seguros
en eeuu por ejemplo el 10 por ciento
ahorita en la actualidad en eeuu no se
usa oro para respaldar pero en este
mundo va a ser 20 por ciento entonces
esto quiere decir que siempre y cuando
en cada momento en el tiempo más del 20
por ciento de estas personas no pidan su
dinero el banco va a ser capaz de ser
líquido va a poder ser capaz de pagar
ese dinero de cumplir su promesa porque
pues estas personas pueden venir y
obtener su dinero ahora para que este
sistema funcione tiene que haber
confianza verdad y pues para que haya
confianza el banco realmente debe de
poder dar dinero cuando la gente lo
necesite el banco debe de mantenerse
líquido debe de tener liquidez
entonces esencialmente lo que hace el
requisito de reserva es que los bancos
se vuelvan líquidos que tengan liquidez
nuestra reserva ahorita es de 71 por
ciento que es muy buena entonces siempre
y cuando no más de 71 por ciento de esta
gente bueno suponiendo que estos
préstamos todavía no los pagan
los de la izquierda verdad esos no los
podemos tener en efectivo pero mientras
71 por ciento de las personas no pidan
su dinero o más de 71 entonces vamos a
estar bien si de repente por alguna
razón así extraña no sé 80% de estas
personas quieren su oro de vuelta
quieren cambiar sus notas bancarias o
sus cuentas de cheques por oro entonces
este banco se le va a acabar el dinero y
eso ya iba a ser un retiro masivo de
efectivo y eso estaba muy mal y eso está
muy mal por varias razones
de repente estas cuentas de cheques pues
parece que ya no están tan padres verdad
porque pues ya no puedes obtener tu
dinero así al instante hay más personas
que piden dinero de lo que hay y la otra
razón es que todo el mundo va a empezar
a desconfiar del sistema y van a decir
no pues no me conviene tener mi dinero
en estas bóvedas entonces a lo mejor no
es tan seguro que va a pasar todo el
mundo va a querer su dinero y otra vez
en este retiros masivos entonces pues
bueno aquí tenemos unos préstamos que
estamos creyendo que sí funcionan y
estos préstamos estamos esperando que
nos lo paguen
en este banco esta es ahorita si tiene
solvencia tiene más activos que pasivos
entonces si le dieran suficiente tiempo
podría pagarle a las personas todas
estas cuentas pero si todas estas
personas de repente vienen y quieren no
solo 500 piezas de oro sino en total
quieren 600 piezas verdad en total ya
vimos que son 700 entonces podrían
querer 600 de repente todo el mundo va a
perder confianza en el sistema estas
personas este probablemente van a querer
todo su dinero entonces porque van a ver
que no hay dinero todos los pasivos se
van a vencer el banco va a tener que
vender sus activos va a tener que
venderle las deudas a alguien más para
obtener piezas de oro vaya se hace todo
un caos y todo un lío es súper súper feo
todo este sistema que estaba basado en
confianza comienza a derrumbarse
entonces con esto regresamos a la
pregunta inicial cuánto es el límite que
puede tener un banco para emitir
préstamos y hacer activos y pasivos pues
justamente el límite está dado por un
cierto requisito de coeficiente de
reserva que establecen los reguladores
es todo por el momento nos vemos